we introduce this idea of Pascal's
triangle and its mysterious connection
to binomials can someone remind me
what's a binder it's two terms it's an
expression in this like a negative B or
an X in a water mix or really any how to
break things you want to put together
two binomial but we're just having an A
and a B what do we do to that object we
raise it to some power whatever how you
want so long as those powers are
integers positive integers we noticed
this we really it passes based on the
sky and if you haven't yet this lesson
you should get it back down okay because
we're losing it okay so we notice this
is strange but we want to be a talk
about this phenomenon in a sensible
[Music]
sorry okay now hopefully it jogs a bit
of your memory that I introduce this
notation because when you have notation
you can talk about things quickly right
you can talk about well I want a
particular number in here and I can
specify very precisely which one it is
so when you see something like this and
see ah or even though there are no
season.this I literally read that as and
CR when you see that what does it mean
what is it refer to the end refers to on
tasker's triangle which row am i all
right
so for example if I wanted to talk about
a number here number key on what row is
this that I'm putting my name in my now
that's the third row remembering that
there is a zero it's right up there okay
and then it goes first row second row
third row so conveniently if you can't
miss what's what you just look at that
second number along there
or should I say the person of them so
that's the third row so if I said 3c
something I know I'm in this row so what
does the army yes fantastic so it's like
which of these coefficients do you want
which number along and just like the
entirety of pencils final which starts
from the zeroth row each row of Pascal's
triangle starts with the zero with turn
right so for example 3 c0 would be this
one he on the number - a group of course
would be 3 c1 ok knock your 3 2 2 3 6 3
and that's the homerun so having this
notation here what I wants to do is that
when you understand these numbers there
are some properties that come from
Pascal's triangle and what happens in a
arm in an actual binder your
anticipation so let's begin by saying
and if you want you to have a little sub
in here underneath this reminder
properties
regardless of what were you are you
regardless of what regularity the zero
in term is always the same
right the zeroth term is this one going
along the left to you right do great
so this he returned in any row is one at
a the same way in the infrared
the in term is also always the same
thing namely one right
remember this is zero first second third
so the third row
in the third term is 1 so how am I going
to state that using this notation right
how can I talk about how I described the
zero of turn in
which of these is the letter number that
describes the term again it's the arse
of it that's a term which turn is it and
this guy is the road so I can take any
road so I'm going to say and see you
know that can literally be anything that
one the zero term is NC 0 that's the
zero term Oliver what about the last
term the last term is going to be NC n
Vanessa and see if they're both equal
because they are both always equal to 1
so this is our first property which
means that if you go to your calculator
and you say 15 see 50 you'll get 100 see
a hundred you can get one every single
time or anything
Ceaser's that's the first moment
the second thing is each row is
symmetrical you notice that like the one
three two one one four six four one so
pause for a minute and think how would
you describe the symmetry possible find
the symmetry of these coefficients how
would you do it in this kind of
notations
okay so firstly MC means you know what
what I'm about to say applies to any row
all right does that make sense that
means I can put it in now I could say X
to be honest like you take any pony
however by convention through some
reason you please eyes are these I think
partly because I'm often the binary we
were expanding it has X's in it so let's
let's avoid using X begin so let's see
um
this could be any term in the world
right it's going to be equal to some
other term in the same row do you agree
with that
so if I'm in the same Road that's the N
throw right okay now let's have a look
at an example I can actually rewrite
Pascal's triangle the whole thing using
this NCR notation so for instance if I
were to replace this row here instead of
writing 1 4 6 8 1
I could write what's the first term in
NCO notation what Ramaiah for throat and
which term is it it's the zero right
there's the first one which of course is
one the next term will be for c1 and
therefore c2 and then I've got the whole
row once I get to NCM which in this case
is 4 so 4 okay so look at the symmetry
right for starters we've already noticed
this symmetry we noticed that was the
first thing they're always equal 1 then
you've got this symmetry and then by the
time you get to there you're already in
the middle so which term is in between
you are too
I think it's given a and - odd isn't it
I think we were talking exes before
right
but think man how this works for siege
now putting $1 for c1
c1 is equal to four see what's in his
face 4-1 do you agree with that in fact
even when you get to the middle tone
which doesn't seem to have a partner you
get 4 C 2 equals 4 C 4 minus 2 well
that's - is it and does that make sense
ok so this is a way of saying the
symmetry for this case but this is far
more general okay all right
probably one copy - I've got four fish
so we're halfway there the third
property is do you remember when I asked
you to add up all of the coefficients in
any individual learner do you remember
the sons of each of the binomial
coefficient rows and a bleep and what
was that path
how is of to do you remember that just
add them up quickly one two for a 16 etc
so how could I state that property in NC
now I'm gonna do this two ways for you
okay firstly I'm just going to do the
long way the only way really that we
know how but you will see quite quickly
the notation I'm gonna show you
cumbersome so I'm going to introduce
even though I does introduce some new
notation
I'm gonna introduce some new news
notation which will help us say this in
a more succinct way so here's what I'm
gonna do
I'll try to say add up all the terms out
of all the twins and I mean add up all
the terms on any word okay so therefore
the first thing I'm gonna say is and see
something because this property about to
give applies to all the words so you
have to be able to say and see whatever
so they like to put any number I like it
what's the first term its nc0 right and
then the next one is NC one what's the
neckline and c2 okay now hold on a
second how many elements I turn from
terms will there be in this row and the
answer is I'm going to get to the nth
term just be careful if I counted them
from 1 2 3 dot dot dot dot dot
eventually I'm going to get 2 n plus 1
if you agree with that have a look at
the fourth row you see it's not 5 times
yeah to be weird there are five terms
the last term is the fourth term it's
because we start from zero okay so
therefore I'm not just going to do this
forever I don't actually know how many
little beings I haven't chosen in so I'm
just gonna say plus dot dot dot and then
the last term I know could be in C here
so what were we saying it was equal to
when you add up everything in a row
powers of two it's two to the power of
something
question.what something it's going to be
n that's convenient isn't it this is one
of the reasons we start counting from
zero it gives us this nice way to
articulate everything here's the fourth
row it adds to 16 16 is 2 to the 4 so
possible okay this is not exhaustive but
for now I'm going to give you one last
little property which is Pascal's
triangle how do you make how do you make
Pascal's triangle again how do you find
out that the next row is 1 5 10 10 5 1
what am i calculating to do that yeah
yeah so you look at the row above you
take two adjacent numbers and you add
them 3 and 1
to give you full oh great okay think I'm
gonna pause for a minute and let you
have it got this before I show you
that's the same question one more time
how would you take that property and
write it in this notation this is how we
talk about the ends of the roads being
one the symmetry of each Road the fact
that everywhere adds up to to the power
of whatever row you're on take a few
minutes because he's actually kind of
tricky and I want you to think about how
you would write this is orange thing
that's happening with this can you have
a go I'll give you some time if you
think you have something come here